[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 20 septembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal préparé
par la rédaction de tv 78 tout de suite
les titres de cette édition
la nouvelle a été officialisée hier soir
il y aura bien une élection municipale
partielle à coignières après la
démission du maire et le désistement de
trois autres élus le conseil municipal
et est incomplet la date du 25 novembre
est avancée pour le scrutin et au moins
trois listes pourraient être candidates
c'est en ce moment la 17e semaine
européenne de la mobilité elle vise à
promouvoir les bonnes pratiques de
transport cette année encore saint
quentin en yvelines s'est associé à
l'opération un forum d'information aux
entreprises s'est tenue ce matin dans
les locaux d'airbus à elancourt et puis
cet événement se tient à quelques jours
des journées nationales de lutte contre
la mucoviscidose la virade des rois est
au programme dimanche à saint germain en
laye un rendez vous sportif et caritatif
au profit de l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose nous recevons sont
organisées
son organisateur franck berger le sport
en fête également dans ce journal avec
des animations ce week end à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines on
en parle avec notre deuxième invité dans
ce journal
vincent couteau coignard connaîtra donc
de nouvelles élections municipales un
scrutin partiel inévitable après la
démission du maire et d'une partie des
conseillers est depuis quelques mois la
situation dans la commune était devenue
intenable les précisions de wilfrid
richy c'est un conseil municipal
incomplet qui s'est réuni mercredi soir
à coignières après la démission du maire
et de trois autres conseillers seuls 25
des 27 sièges étaient pourvus face à
cette situation le préfet a décidé de
convoquer une élection partielle
intégral la commune de coignières va se
représenter devant les électeurs ce que
je trouve très démocratique si en quoi
n'y a rien de voir l'équipe qu'elle veut
avoir pour gouverner cette ville
dominique catelin qui sera selon toute
vraisemblance tête de liste lors du
scrutin la date du 25 novembre est
avancé en attendant le conseil municipal
se chargera comme le veut la loi de
gérer les affaires courantes
lors de la campagne la voie du deuxième
adjoint du
or des missionnaires avec qui il était
rentré en conflit elle devrait se faire
entendre
je vais essayer de réunir surtout
l'équivalent d'une trentaine de
personnes et les faire intervenir et
agir vraiment pour qu'elle soit motivée
pour chose qu'elles choisissent elles
mêmes les têtes de liste je suis pas
pour le culte de la personnalité en ce
qui me concerne je n'ai jamais été donc
voilà par contre si c'est choisi
effectivement en toute conscience et en
toute liberté par un groupe
ma foi à mes yeux ça une valeur morale
moral plus importante
et puis candidat déjà déclaré didier
fischer l'opposant socialiste qui en
2014 avait totalisé 43 % des suffrages
ça paraît la meilleure des solutions à
l'heure actuelle compte tenu des
divisions de la majorité
compte tenu du fait que de toutes façons
on n'était plus en mesure de gérer
correctement cette ville bientôt on
allait avoir le budget complémentaire à
voter ce budget complémentaire n'aurait
pas pu être votée à partir de ce moment
là nous aurions été dans une situation
de blocage et c'est préjudiciable aux
poignets rien et à la ville d'une
manière générale
reste à savoir si une fois élu le
nouveau conseil pourra mettre les
rancoeurs deux côtés d'autant que les
dossiers importants ne manquent pas et
notamment celui d'une participation à la
création d'une piscine intercommunale
avec maurepas elancourt dans l'actualité
du jour activity et l'école de la
deuxième chance des yvelines ont signé
une convention ce jeudi un engagement
financier de lagence d'insertion du
département à hauteur de 200 mille euros
pour 2018 ce partenariat a pour but de
favoriser l'insertion des jeunes issus
des quartiers prioritaires est de son
côté l'école de la deuxième chance déjà
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines va
ouvrir un nouvel établissement à
chanteloup les vignes et développer de
nouveaux projets écoutez ses propos au
micro de nicolas landry concrètement
aujourd'hui le projet qu'on va faire
émerger pour l'école de la 2ème chance
avec le département ce avec des
boutiques écoles par exemple donc une
boutique qu'on va on va prendre dans un
projet pédagogique où les jeunes vont
tout gérer de a à z
l'accueil la caisse la vente les
produits qu'on vend dans les dents
la boutique en fin de compte c'est faire
proposerait pour leur donner le goût
d'être travail sont des métiers de la
vente pour activity nous il est
essentiel qu'on signe une convention
avec l'école de la seconde chance parce
qu'il nous manquait un partenaire en
direction des jeunes on souhaite signer
cette convention avec un objectif qui
soit d'environ 400 jeunes parents
accompagnés c'est en ce moment la
semaine européenne de la mobilité pour
l'occasion saint quentin en yvelines
organise depuis à lundi des forums
d'information dans les entreprises du
territoire
aux côtés de ses partenaires aujourd'hui
il était au site d'airbus des feuns n
space à elancourt sur place isabelle
kareyce causse saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la première communauté d'agglomération à
avoir approuvé son plan local de
déplacement révisé dans ce contexte la
semaine européenne de la mobilité est l
occasion pour l'agglomération d'animer
des forums d'innovation au sein des
entreprises du territoire
tout au long de la semaine l'intérêt de
ce type d'initiative en entreprise et
devenir au contact des usagers salariés
typiquement cette année on a mis en
place un nouveau service le service de
la vélostation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines élite aisée de
venir présenter le service aux salariés
en leur montrant pour ceux qui viennent
par exemple en train
la possibilité de faire le dernier km en
vélo pour airbus défunte chaîne space
dont un des sites est implantée à
elancourt cette mise en place est née
notamment de la volonté de six
entreprises du territoire de créer un
plan de déplacement inter entreprises
nous cherchons développer les moyens de
transport alternatifs pour deux raisons
la première c'est baisser
le nombre de voitures sur le site la
deuxième c'est de toucher une population
que l'on recherche qui sont les
passionnés d'informatique très citadin
qui n'aiment pas la voiture des citadins
qui refusent de plus en plus la voiture
au profit de solutions innovantes de
transport partagé comme le covoiturage
ou le vélo services qui sont d'autant
alternative à la voiture individuelle
complémentaire des transports publics
en fait courir le matin jeux dont
certains en cinq minutes de bus donc je
me suis dis qu'effectivement une
location de l'eau ça pourrait justement
simplifier les déplacements les nombreux
partenaires de l'événement comme la sncf
pour toul où vélostation sont au rendez
vous de ces forums de la mobilité en
entreprise
les travaux de réaménagement avait
débuté en février dernier hier mercredi
le nouveau square de rohan a été
inauguré à maurepas un ensemble de 2185
mètres carrés dans le quartier de la
marnière avec désormais le deux heures
de jeu un sentier de promenade et des
appareils de remise en forme pour les
seniors cette réhabilitation intervient
après celle du square du beaufortain
réalisé l'an passé et prochainement
c'est le square de ré qui sera modernisé
en centre ville c'est un événement à la
fois sportif et caritatif ce dimanche le
domaine national du château de
saint-germain-en-laye accueille l'as
avira des rois c'est un rendez-vous au
profit de l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose on en parle avec vous
franck berger bonsoir danse on aimerait
vous êtes le secrétaire général adjoint
de l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose organisateurs de cette
virade des rois alors cet événement se
déroule dans le cadre d'une opération
nationale de votre association qui
s'appelle el aydi rate de l'espoir 350
rendez-vous qui sont organisées partout
en france quel est le concept et quels
sont les objectifs de cette opération
alors les virades de l'espoir c'est très
important pour l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose puisque c'est l'événement
national qui a lieu tous les ans le
dernier week-end de septembre
il a lieu à saint germain en laye le
dimanche 23 septembre donc une semaine
avant pour cause de ryder cup je crois
que vous êtes bien placé pour
effectivement être n'en parle dans ce
journal
voilà c'est un vrai sujet et donc on a
avancé d'une semaine par rapport donc
finalement olemps les virades au niveau
national une semaine avant mais les
virades de l'espoir c'est extrêmement
important puisque en fait on recueille 5
plus de 50% en fait du budget au niveau
national un peu plus de 5 millions
d'euros grâce à la générosité du public
qu'on attire sur les virades de l'espoir
un événement primordial pour financer
les actions l'association financer la
recherche aussi exactement il ya 350
virades en france et on attire
effectivement le grand public pour
donner son souffle contre la
mucoviscidose et surtout donner son
souffle pour ceux qui en manquent
c'est le cas en fait des patients et des
malades atteints de mucoviscidose
donc cette virade de l'espoir à
saint-germain-en-laye lancera ce cycle
nationale qui se déroulera donc le
week-end d'après alors dans les yvelines
sa porte le nom de virades des rois on
imagine c'est un hommage un clin d'oeil
en tout cas au passé royal de saint
germain en laye c'était la résidence une
résidence royale pendant de nombreuses
années smith et la 19ème édition à saint
germain en laye et effectivement c'est
un clin d'oeil et c'est que pour saint
germain en laye d'ailleurs c'est la
virade des rois virades de l'espoir pour
vaincre la mucoviscidose donc à saint
germain et c'est effectivement un clin
d'oeil à puisque c'est le berceau en
fait de la naissance de louis xiv
voilà alors pour nos téléspectateurs
faisons un point sur ce qu'est la
mucoviscidose et combien de personnels
concernant france lors la mucoviscidose
est une maladie en fait génétique
s'il m'a dit qui restera même si c'est
la plus courante en france
elle atteint aujourd'hui sept minutes
patients on a dépassé les un peu plus de
50 % d'adultes ça veut dire qu'on
progresse aussi dans la lutte contre la
mucoviscidose
mais c'est une maladie qui a pour
conséquence l'épaississement du mucus et
donc l'encombrement des bronches les
infections pulmonaires pulmonaire pardon
la perte en fait de capacités
respiratoires satin aussi le
l'appareil digestif donc c'est une
maladie qui ne se voit pas mais qui est
extrêmement contraignante et avec
beaucoup de traitements tous les jours
avec beaucoup de médicaments avec des
séances de kiné de kennedy et de
traitements contre ces infections lors
les lions ont progrès sur cette maladie
où en est la recherche aujourd'hui ce
qu'il ya des traitements pour mieux
vivre avec cette maladie
on a vu en 2015 le premier traitement
contre la cause de la mucoviscidose il
faut savoir qu'il ya plusieurs me coxyde
ozon n'a pas qu'une
donc c'est un traitement qui a dessiné a
trop peu de malades encore donc même si
l'espérance de vie augmente elle était
de 7 ans en 1965 elle est aujourd'hui
d'un peu plus de 40 ans pour les enfants
qui naissent aujourd'hui mais la moyenne
malheureusement des gens qui partent
atteint nuque aussi une vie si d'oser
est inférieure encore à 30 ans
donc vous voyez que le chemin est encore
long et donc on a besoin d'ingénieurs
une générosité du public
on a besoin des dons et on a besoin que
vous veniez nous voir en fait sur les
virades de l'espoir au niveau national
et à saint germain en laye le dimanche
23 septembre justement dans ce combat
quel est le rôle de l'association
vaincre la mucoviscidose
alors on a plusieurs missions la
première mission vous l'avez compris
c'est lutter contre la maladie
sur le plan de la recherche donc là on a
on est les premiers financeurs en fait
de la recherche en france on mobilise 3
millions d'euros tous les ans pour des
appels à projets c'est aussi soigner les
malades
c'est à dire que tous ces malades lasson
son suivi ensemble de compétences et et
de recherche en micro ici doses en dans
le 78 nous avons la chance d'avoir
l'hôpital mignot à versailles qui est
vraiment proche des malades
et puis c'est aussi accompagner et
améliorer la qualité de vie des patients
donc vous voyez ces démissions qui
demande beaucoup de moyens encore une
fois on est les pratiquement les seuls
financeurs de la recherche et du soutien
aux malades en france donc on a besoin
de beaucoup d'argent on a besoin de
beaucoup dont on a besoin de beaucoup de
générosité du public
revenons aux virades des rois pour
terminer cet entretien quel est le
programme de la journée c'est un
programme à la fois sportif caritatif
pour cette journée et festif et festive
bien sûr donc on déroge pas à la règle
la virade de l'espoir c'est aussi donner
son souffle donc le matin
des courses donc 5 km et 10 km et une
marche de 2 5 km donc vous voyez que là
on attire un petit peu les sportifs les
femmes les familles donc c'est vraiment
fait pour tout le monde
on enchaîne avec un pique nique géant
les domaine nationale de saint germain
nous autorise cette journée-là à à
pique-niqué sur l'herbe
et puis ensuite on propose des baptêmes
en voitures anciennes des baptêmes en
harley davidson avec le paris ouest
capteurs qui est art au cheval et puis
on enchaîne avec des concerts dans le
cadre de l'estival nantes le festival de
musique de saint germain en laye avec un
premier concert qui aura lieu de 14h à
15h qui s'appelle seconde nation et qui
est un spectacle de musique acadienne
et puis on enchaînera avec le groupe
rockincher de 15h à 16h30 au tour de new
country donc de la pop et de la country
gros programme pour terminer questions
plus pratiques et ce qu'il reste encore
des places pour participer à cette
virade et éco et si oui comment
participer
oui complètement les inscriptions sont
encore ouvertes le 10 km les
inscriptions sont fermées parce que
c'est chronométrés il ya un certificat
médical qui était demandé mais pour le 5
km les marches vous présenter à 9 heures
dans le parc du château et vous
inscrivez sur place et on vous
accueillera évidemment avec plaisir un
mot rapide on peut vous souhaiter quoi
du monde du soleil pour le monde du
soleil est effectivement beaucoup de
dons et on peut retrouver toutes les
informations sur cet événement sur le
site internet ad de la vieja des rois
qui s'affiche merci franck berger
d'avoir été avec six avoue je rappelle
secrétaire général adjoint de
l'association vaincre la mucoviscidose
et vous êtes l'organe l'organisateur de
cette 19e virades des rois elle la coupe
du monde de golf se rapprochent top
départ mardi prochain à saint quentin en
yvelines la fièvre de la ryder cup a
également touché l uv est ce qu
l'université a organisé hier mercredi et
aujourd'hui la jungers cup une
compétition opposant des étudiants
français et étrangers reportage de
michael et nidau des polos rouges et
bleus sur un parcours de golf ce
mercredi 19 septembre l'esprit de la
ryder cup s'est emparé du golfe isabella
de plaisir à l'occasion de la première
édition de la young hearts cup
le concept la compétition oppose des
étudiants français et étrangers
rendez vous imaginé et organisé par nous
cité de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines pour martin en personne était
la mère du rejet commun s'il fallait que
j'ai à la fois des relais au niveau des
étudiants français dont j'ai sollicité
les professeurs des universités
franciliennes et du côté étranger dans
un premier temps j'essayais d'avoir des
relais auprès des écoles britanniques
américaines de la région parisienne
au total quatorze joueurs huit français
et six étrangers ont répondu présents
pour ce rendez vous elle je trouve que
l'idée super cool de faire une
compétition juste avant la ryder cup
faut avoir le feeling oui j'aime j'aime
bien ça permet de vivre un peu mieux la
ryder cup un peu plus ensemble voilà
c'est génial parmi les étudiants ont
retrouvé notamment la fille de la
légende du golf français jean van de
velde joueurs sur la ryder cup en 1999
est en franco suisse alexandre a enfilé
le temps d'une journée le polo des états
unis et non pas de l'europe comme son
père ça me fait un peu bizarre je pense
que mon père va être très content mais
après les matches la journée s'est
terminée au club house par un quiz sur
la ryder cup les deux équipes ont dû se
creuser les méninges pour répondre à une
dizaine de questions de culture générale
sur la compétition dans la mesure où cet
événement est porté par l'université il
fallait qu'une petite connotation donc
culturelle
voilà donc on a essayé de mêler culture
et sport la compétition s'est clôturé ce
jeudi 20 septembre golf de jardy à
vaucresson
une deuxième édition pourrait être
organisé dans deux ans lors d'une
prochaine ryder cup
suite et fin de la découverte du
parcours de cette ryder cup 2018 que
nous vous proposions toute cette semaine
est dernier focus sur le trou numéro 18
tous les joueurs termineront leur parti
devant plus de 20000 spectateurs
elle les présentations de ce trou par le
directeur adjoint du golf national
philippe pilate haut on est sur le
dernier trou du parcours la lacrosse
appelle la foule la poule
pourquoi parce que ben habituellement
derniers trous avaient choqué beaucoup
de monde qui suivaient les dernières
parties donc là c'est un par 4 qui est
un des trous les plus difficiles de par
ses moyens des scores l'open de france
qu'on peut trouver sur le sur les
circuits européens c'est un long par 4
qui fait 431 m bull a encore une fois la
mise en jeu va être primordial pourquoi
parce que nous on a encore de l'obstacle
d'eau cette fois ci sur la partie gauche
du fairway et on a également sur la
partie droite des des bunkers qu'on ne
voit pas du départ mis à part celui qui
l'a extrémités droite et
qui attendent qu'une seule chose c'est
de recevoir les balles de façon à rendre
la tacc de green jouable à
ou alors si le voir prend le risque
prend des risques c'est conséquent et
qui peut avoir des conséquences assez
dramatique pour l'issue d'un match
[Musique]
donc là le deuxième coup une fois que le
voir à millas la balle ici sur la mise
en jeu 2e poule n'est pas donné et a
toujours le vent qui pousse un peu
légèrement contre sur ce coup là assez
régulièrement donc qui rallongent quand
même le trou et surtout l'obstacle d'eau
créé devant avec le green qui fuit un
tout petit peu pourquoi parce que en
fait le green est beaucoup plus étroit
sur la partie droite ce qui veut dire
que un coût qui sera pas forcément bien
toucher un club pas forcément bien
choisi avec le vent qui pousse à droite
avec une balle qui sera peut-être pas
forcément touché formidablement bien
le coût sera quand même pénalisé avec
avec l'obstacle d'eau devant
[Musique]
ce green du trou numéro 18 est un crime
très compliquée à jouer pourquoi parce
que si on n'a pas joué une attaque de
l'une proche du drapeau avec toutes les
pentes qu'on peut y trouver
on peut facilement facilement prendre 1
3 voire un peu plus de 3 peu de sueur
sur ce green l'a pas oublié certains
joueurs encore une fois en relation avec
l'open de france ont perdu des tourments
ici tout simplement parce que trop loin
du drapeau parce que pas assez attentif
sur les pentes et se retrouver sur des
dépositions de deux fuyards les tournois
ou un bandeau liste est vraiment
beaucoup trop loin du trou pour le
gagner donc là maintenant ce qu'il faut
c'est attendre avec impatience les
joueurs qui vont les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux les 24 meilleurs mondiaux qui
vont venir qui vont venir à la fin du
mois à battre le faire pour gagner ce
trophée magique et la ryder cup sur ce
magnifique parcours qui est le parcours
de l'albatros
ce week-end c'est la fête du sport un
événement national qui aura lieu
notamment à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines à samedi et dimanche
c'est de 13h à 18h pour en parler 20
francs couteau dont soir on sort êtes le
responsable du pôle événementiel et
communication à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines un événement
national dont quels sont les objectifs
de la fête du sport
alors là c'est vraiment la première
édition de cette fête du sport
l'objectif national s'est il est triple
c'est vraiment amener les français à
pratiquer une activité physique
régulière et donc se rapprocher aussi
dit mouvement sportif pour pratiquer de
façon encadrée
et donc meilleure des façons c'est aussi
rendre hommage aux bénévoles aux
milliers ou dizaines de milliers de
bénévoles qui permettent aujourd'hui
quel mouvement sportif puisse vivre et
que ce genre d'action puisse tenir aussi
justement
et puis du coup c'est mettre en avant
aussi d'autres activités à plus original
donc ça c'est un peu le credo qu'on a
choisi de nous sur les idées loisirs
on m'a présenté le programme juste après
il sera d'ailleurs possible sur cet
événement de faire un bilan de sa
condition physique de ça tout à fait
avec les tests forme plus donc c'est le
comité régional du sport pour tous qui
en partenariat avec la fédération
d'athlétisme met en place ces tests donc
ça consiste en une batterie de cinq ou
six tests accessible je vous rassure sur
la force la souplesse l'endurance et
donc on mouline tout ça dans une machine
informatiquement
et donc ça ne donne vraiment ça situe un
peu le niveau physique la forme physique
de la personne et le but ce n'est pas de
juger évidemment mais c'est au contraire
de conseiller sur la pratique sportive
la bonne pratique sportive liée à la
condition physique de la personne alors
sur le programme vous le disiez samedi
et dimanche c'est tout un village
d'activités sportives qui sera proposé à
lille de loisirs des activités estivales
et aussi innovante un peu insolite qu'on
pourra pratiquer sur place oui tout à
fait et d'activités comme le coq cibola
par exemple le coccyx voilà le principe
c'est en jouant un peu comme au
badminton donc deux contre deux avec un
filet au milieu et on a un mini
trampoline demain un petit un petit
carré de tissu qu'on va attendre pour
faire partir la balle en hauteur et donc
l'envoyer dans le camp adverse
d'accord donc c'est vraiment sympa on a
différentes techniques en plus
appréhendé avec avec le moniteur qui
sera présent sur place quelle autre
genre d'activité il y aura des balades
encadrées en ski à roulettes
voilà donc sur l'île des loisirs au bord
de l'étang ça va être sympa aussi
et puis on a d'autres activités comme de
10 yoga qu'on a peu l'occasion
finalement de voir sur sur les loisirs
en tout cas de l' escalade du badminton
du rugby risquerait le vélo smoothie
j'ai entendu parler de cet outil qui
permet de faire du sport tout en faisant
un smoothie donc on profite à près de sa
séance de sport exactement l'avant
l'adage
après après l'effort le réconfort a
toute sa place
donc le principe c'est de pédaler pour
faire tourner le mixeur et puis aimé
voir un beau un bon cocktail de fruits
de fruits et légumes frais ces activités
sont gratuites
entièrement gratuite et on a voulu
promouvoir encore plus cette fête du
sport en mettant en place la gratuité d
accès d accès véhicules pour tout le
monde jusqu'à 18 heures parce que c'est
la fin des activités
il y aura aussi le goal le golf blue
green qui s'associe aussi à l'événement
qui est présent sur l'île de loisirs qui
proposera des initiations golf ça
complètement donc c'est sur inscription
donc je vous conseille d'aller voir sur
le site de bluegreen ou celui dit de
loisirs donc le bug le col pour green
s'associe à la fête du sport mais aussi
le ska équitation avec la fête nationale
du cheval et les petits les petits jeux
de la placette multi jeux qui proposent
à 50% de réduction sur l'achat des jeux
donc vraiment toutes les de loisirs vous
accueillera pour la fête du sport que
vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est aussi
l'occasion de mettre en avant les
bénévoles du monde sportif est ce qu'ils
seront présents est ce qu'il y aura des
clubs sportifs des bénévoles sportifs
présents tout à fait nous c'est vraiment
une politique de l'île des loisirs
depuis de nombreuses années maintenant
c'est s'appuyer sur le mouvement sportif
local alors quand je dis local c'est
saint quentinois mais aussi yvelinois et
franciliens puisqu'on est on rayonne
plus largement que sur saint quentin en
yvelines et donc on s'appuie par exemple
sur le comité départemental de rugby qui
va venir avec des clubs sur le comité
régional sport pour tous sur le comité
départemental de badminton et on a
invité aussi d'autres bénévoles comme la
fpt qui pendant dix ans a organisé
plusieurs événements chez nous et donc
on les a invités aussi à profiter de cet
événement ce week end
merci dans son couteau pour ces
précisions merci au responsable du pôle
événementiel et communication à lille de
loisirs de 50
en yvelines la fête du sport c'est
samedi et dimanche toutes les
informations le programme complet est à
retrouver sur le site de l'île de
loisirs et pour plus d'idées sorties
loisirs ce week-end je vous invite à
regarder à l'émission 7,8 loisirs c'est
juste après ce journal avant de vous
laisser le portrait de la semaine
plasticienne et sculptrice valérie à
l'oiseau cherche avant tout à exprimer
ses émotions avec le matériau le plus
adapté une expression qui prend forme
avec les ce temple livre d'artiste ou
encore la sculpture installée en vallée
de chevreuse elle vient de participer
aux journées du patrimoine rencontre
signée jules colis comment partager sa
propre perception de la nature par l'art
voilà la question que s'est posée
l'artiste mesniloise valérie d'oiseaux
pour le projet aux artistes le
patrimoine du pnr de la vallée de
chevreuse c'est avec une installation
nommée polyphonie chromatique qui
prendra place à la ferme de bourrins
qu'elle tente d'y répondre
quand le ce projet de darré patrimoine a
été proposé j'ai perçu ça comme un
insigne habitant juste à côté qui avait
la ferme qui était juste à côté
travaillant sur le thème deschamps
puisque ça fait deux ans que dans mon
processus de travail la couleur apparaît
je me suis proposé pour ce projet j'ai
rédigé donc un un dossier qui explicite
et l'idée de départ le principe c'était
d'essayer de faire percevoir à la fois
la tonalité des chants toute la variété
que peuvent prendre les couleurs et les
graphismes champêtre mais en même temps
comment une architecture rural qui n'a
pas entre guillemets un but esthétique à
sa propre harmonie esthétique une ferme
elle est d'abord construite pour sa
nécessité son principe d'existence et
pas pour sa beauté comme un château on
cherche plus à à une esthétique une
harmonie à un équilibre là l'équilibré
dans sa fonctionnalité
suite à une grande période d'observation
de cet espace à différentes saisons
valérie a choisi de mettre en place 16
grandes gravure peintes sur les
ouvertures de la ferme
une technique mûrement réfléchie pour
proposer une double lecture à cette
oeuvre est le principe du projet c'est
que la vision m
deux possibilités on va voir là les
grandes peintures et les gravures de la
route donc à une centaine de mètres donc
là on aura que des monochromes de
couleurs et plus on va s'approcher de la
de la ferme et des murs et la plus on va
rentrer dans le graphisme de la gravure
et on va apercevoir les subtilités des
motifs quand je suis dans les champs
belges éprouvent des émotions des
sensations autant par la lumière que par
la couleur du coup j'essaie de voir
comment je peux faire remonter la
sensation la gravure pour ça permet cet
effet là puisque on superpose les images
on que légèrement les décalés quand on
refait une réimpression par dessus on
obtient du coup un effet vibratoire qui
se rapproche un peu de la réalité c'est
aussi de pouvoir échanger à un moment
donné entre la perception du paysage que
j'ai et la perception du paysage que les
gens en ont une perception à partager
gratuitement du 15 septembre au 9
octobre au mesnil saint denis
l'occasion de redécouvrir à travers la
gravure les variations de couleurs des
champs au cours des saisons
c'est la fin de cette édition de demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 l'hebdo présenté par nicolas landry
et non se retrouvent dès lundi pour un
nouveau journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]